hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
today i wanted to give you an office
tour i wanted to share with you why i
designed it the way that i did why i
bought certain pieces whether i still
like them or not after living with them
for many many months so stay tuned so
firstly i want to address that this
whole thing my whole office came
together over two years of
transformation this is not something
that i like thought of and did in like a
month like it was a very slow process of
living in the space using the space and
then figuring out slowly how i wanted to
transform it to make it fit my needs and
so i kind of came up with like these
core principles of how i wanted to
design my space and how i wanted to use
it the first is that i wanted to be
relatively flexible like i don't really
change my space like every month or so
but if i wanted to change the look and
feel and vibe of the space and the
energy of this space i can i also wanted
to be easy to clean up i didn't want it
to be like this whole thing that it took
like an hour every week to clean i
didn't want to have wires everywhere and
cords because that's something that as
soon as you like amass certain amounts
of equipment for youtube it just you
start getting like spider webs of wires
everywhere and i really wanted to avoid
that and then lastly in terms of how i
wanted this space to feel i wanted to
feel like playful and comfortable and
safe like i was going to do some of my
most vulnerable work in here as i wrote
videos and brainstormed ideas and like
challenged myself to things that i
didn't think i could challenge myself in
so let's dive into each space the first
that i want to talk about is of course
the desk area and now there's a couple
of components to this desk area the
first of which is the desk itself i've
talked about my desk a bunch on this
channel i have the jarvis desk from
fully and
it's great i've it's like a long time
favorite and there are many reasons why
i like it it's a sit stand desk and it's
also on rolling casters so really this
desk is flexible in however way i want
to use it in case i wanted to move it to
like a different part of the room or if
i wanted to be standing and sitting and
alternating throughout the day and in
terms of the things that are on my desk
i have several videos where i've talked
about that so i'll link them right here
in the card and the description box down
below but yeah things like my monitor my
computer my keyboard and mouse desk mat
how i mount my computer the speakers
charging ports lighting all of those
things i've spent like a meticulous
amount of time choosing each one
intentionally to really fit my needs so
yeah i won't go into that too much
because there's literally entire videos
about that so give those a watch so the
next zone that i want to talk about is
part of my desk area is the bookshelf so
this is positioned to the left of my
desk and it kind of serves as almost
like a privacy screen as well my door is
right behind that and so without it i
see my dogs and my husband walking by
and whoever else is at home and
it's kind of distracting honestly and so
having a bookshelf there so that i can
really focus on what's going on in front
of me at my desk without being
distracted about what's going on outside
has been really nice the bookshelf is
the ikea calyx uh which is like the cube
shelf that everybody has ikea always
sells them it comes in so many different
colors we actually brought it from our
other house where it served a different
purpose but i thought it would be really
perfect here and it has been it's been
some really great like visible storage
and decoration and again the privacy
part has been really nice the next zone
of my desk area is behind the desk now
this is a recent improvement i talked
about this in my desk accessories video
but i added these sound tiles from felt
right as well as this floating shelf to
give the space a little bit more visual
interest before i put this up it was
just like a blank white wall which is
totally fine but i wanted to add some
visual interest some color some texture
because i'm sitting facing this wall
like most of the day and i really liked
the colors of these felt right tiles and
i wanted a place to put one of my plants
and to be honest with you putting this
right behind my desk has kind of given
my desk like an identity it's kind of
like okay this is like a whole area that
is set because look at how well it's
decorated so
i really think it's brought everything
together and then the last part of my
desk area that i want to talk about is
my storage cabinet to the right of my
desk this is also a pretty recent
addition i got this from ikea i forgot
which one it's called but i wanted just
some more storage and some easy access
to storage for things like pens and
pencils and stationery and laptops and
books and stuff like that i also really
like that it provides some storage on
top right now i have my printer on there
but i genuinely and generally don't
really want to put that much stuff on my
desk i want to keep my desk area itself
pretty clean and so having some extra
areas to just place stuff on top of has
been really nice and before we move on i
want to say a quick thank you to helix
sleep helix sleep is a company that
creates premium mattresses customized to
fit your needs shipped directly to your
door i myself own two helix sleep
mattresses and they are legitimately the
best mattresses i've ever had they're so
good i get great night sleep from them
every night genuinely a really really
great mattress company helix's sleep
quiz matches you with the perfect
mattress based on your body type and
sleep preferences i myself am kind of
like a back and side sleeper and i
prefer like a medium firm mattress and
so the one that i have is the dusk luxe
mattress helix delivers your mattress
straight to your door with free shipping
in the u.s and the mattress comes rolled
up in a box and it's really easy to set
up and if you're nervous about buying
something you haven't tried before
especially something like a mattress
which is one of the most expensive
purchases you make in your home then
there's a 100 night sleep trial to make
sure that you really like it before you
fully commit to it they include a
10-year warranty and they offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so visit
helixsleep.com to get up to 200 off your
helix mattress plus two free pillows
thank you so much to helix for
sponsoring i cannot say enough good
things about this mattress company i've
sent this mattress to a few of my
friends who were like setting up their
own space for the first time and they've
all said wonderful things about it so if
you're looking for a mattress then
definitely buy this one all right now
let's get back to the video so let's
move on to the next part of my office
and i'm going to call this like the
lounge area i guess aka like where i'm
sitting right now this this is the area
i'm talking about all right so the first
part of this lounge area is of course
the couch i got this from ikea it's the
center hum series that is like beloved
has been around for a long time i bought
this one specifically because i liked
how low it was i wanted a couch that
wasn't gonna have a huge footprint in my
room and the reason why i wanted a couch
in the space to begin with is because i
wanted an alternate seating space like
yes i'm going to stay on my chair the
whole day but it'd be nice to not have
to and have some options and so it's
been really nice to have it for that
reason as well as just filming it
creates a really nice filming spot i
film for my videos and i wanted to make
this look really nice and what can i say
the dogs love napping on it i like
napping on it but i will say it's not
too comfortable like i don't feel like i
can sit here all day and feel totally
fine uh it is a little bit flatter than
a lot of other couches which i think for
like a work room it's perfect because i
don't want to just melt into my couch in
my work room and the next part of my
like studio lounge space is this art
wall right here so when i was first
designing the space i was thinking maybe
i should do a gallery wall or maybe i
should do this art ledge and i opted for
the art ledge in the end because i
thought it would be a lot easier to be
flexible with the art that i wanted to
display at any given moment and so the
ledge itself i did look at a bunch of
different options online but i ended up
building mine i grabbed a few pieces of
unfinished pine wood i think they're
like the premium kind from lowe's and i
put it together with a couple of screws
and nails and i also made sure to pick
the pieces of wood that were the
straightest so it's easy to put together
and also the one that has like the best
texture i really liked this kind of look
to it i actually ended up keeping it
unfinished because i like the raw
organic natural feel of the wood and so
it's been great and the last thing that
i did to really customize this side of
the office is lighting now i worked in a
lot of office environments before and
i've definitely stayed past the sun
going down and every office space to me
can be described as like white
incandescent lighting like that is that
is what an office means to me but i
really didn't want it to feel like that
because the reality of it is there are
going to be times where i'm going to
work past sunset and i didn't want it to
feel like sterile or corporate i wanted
to still feel like homey and cozy so i
put two lamps on each end of the wall
and they have a really kind of warm bulb
in them and so at night it becomes
really cozy in here it's actually not
too bright
but it's not too dark for things and the
lamp that is on the floor i got from
ikea and the one that's hanging i bought
the orb and the cord from the color cord
company but i built the mount myself i
get a lot of compliments about the
lighting in my room there's a lot of
things in interior design world that
says the lighting and how you light a
space can really change how you view the
space and how it feels and so especially
in the evening which is when i turn
these lights on
it just creates a really nice like cozy
safe and playful but like homey
atmosphere which at the end of the day
my office is in my home so that's what i
wanted and the last area of my office is
the window so i chose this room
specifically because an entire wall of
this room is a window a bay window and
it's kind of western facing and so i get
some really nice light filtering in in
the afternoons and it's what lights my
videos like literally i only have the
window to light my video right now and
so the window itself is a bay window and
there's a kind of a little ledge that
was built in and i wanted to be able to
utilize this space and just use the
storage inside so i created this cushion
on top so the seat cushion itself that i
put on top i made myself by watching a
bunch of youtube videos i bought the
fabric the batting and the cushion
itself from joann's and then i spent a
weekend building it um i will say the
dogs love laying here because it gets
direct sunlight and it's a really nice
again an alternative seating spot in my
office which i just want to make lots of
alternative seating here so that i can
just sit wherever i want and because
this window gives such good lighting
this is also where i put my plants
luckily the plants don't burn here and
they seem very happy granted i could
probably water this one but yeah i just
wanted a lot of greenery in my room as
well because i feel like that makes a
room again feel homey and organic and
not sterile and corporate feeling uh and
so yeah it's been nice to just work
alongside plants honestly and take care
of them while i work so that's
everything in my office i will make sure
to leave everything linked in the
description box down below again i've
dived into like various parts of my
office in different videos and so i'll
link the description box in case you
want to dive into any specific things
but some of them are old some of them
are outdated i've changed them since
then but at the end of the day i think a
space that you live in is supposed to
grow and change with you and so i'm
really happy with how it turned out and
i doubt that this is the last version of
the office that i have but i'm happy
with where it's at and i just i kind of
want to document it and show you all
where it's at right now let me know what
you think in the comments down below
hopefully you all are working on an
office yourself whether it be a separate
room or in your bedroom or in your
living room or whatever i think it's
really fun really great place and
opportunity to like unleash some
creativity and make something your own
so let me know how it goes don't forget
to subscribe to this channel if you
haven't done so already and i will see
you next time bye
[Music]